we've shown you many examples of violent
clashes involving Mt but you'll remember
that but now President Trump says he may
classify the group as a terrorist
organization the president blasting the
mass agitators on Twitter and saying
doing so would make it easier for police
to do their jobs and remember
conservative journalists and II know who
was assaulted while covering an N type
of protest in Portland Oregon last month
he's now speaking out in support of the
president's idea this will provide a
framework for local authorities and
especially federal authorities to start
investigating this criminal cartel for
the street thugs that they are but in
addition to the street hooliganism that
we see over and over on the streets of
America this movement also has a
political ideology that is agitating for
a violent political revolution it's been
four weeks since my beating and robbery
outside the Justice on Tehran eclis
there's not been a single arrest I want
to get to the rest point in a second but
to prove that I did prepare for this
segment even though I wasn't prepared at
that moment so the question is you can
think outside the box and on terrorism
but not outside the Constitution so when
it comes to mt5 I'm curious what you
think reg there you cannot have
protected speech if your speech is used
to help criminals create acts of
violence make sense a simple solution is
to remove masks in public settings yeah
because they're only wearing masks to
escape the consequences of their violent
actions I'm not gonna blame that you
know I'm not gonna blame the Democrats
Oh blame the media Antipa is and I think
that one will agree with me on this Andy
Paul is a very small violent group of
losers they don't represent the
Democratic Party I don't like it when
they do that with the all right people
and I think they but they do find
shelter in the greater belief that if
you're your adversary isn't wrong it's
evil the old Krauthammer line so that
way if you believe your adversary is
evil as opposed to wrong that justifies
violence that narrative has been pushed
by the by the media so anti-fog merely
really the white dandruff falling from
CNN's head that is something that is
blaming the media that's very good this
hasn't changed them could have stayed
the show 45 seconds
stop and the constitutional trying yeah
if this is allowed right it's President
Trump where he to go through this and it
were to pass muster goes to Supreme
Court Supreme Court says this fine
what's to stop other groups then from
being targeted in the same way now not
that other groups use the masks i think
the mask is an important to take the
argument for an Tifa being a terrorist
organizations because they're using
violence to reach a political end right
so there then are problems with
citizenship these are American citizens
can you designate internal terrorist
organizations if they are citizens
what's the criteria you can also
designate groups like this as gangs
which gives law enforcement more ability
to target them you know different groups
of people so I can different that your
militias right all of that but I agree
with Gregg in the sense that no and Tifa
doesn't represent all Democrats however
Democrats have been protecting aunt Eva
for example and Ino says that no one has
been arrested as a result of his its
Portland it Allah saw almost dying as a
result of that the Portland mayor has
you know claimed that he condemns it but
hasn't made an effort to actually arrest
these people and when people in
Washington DC are asked about this
Democrats they run away and don't answer
the question whereas with the Tea Party
which was not a violent group using
violence as a political ends to Amin
they were accused of all these things in
every single Republican across the
country was asked to condemn them over
free speech actually that is that's an
important definition of terrorism Jesse
is to try to advance your political
goals through violent means your
thoughts any thoughts from now on I kind
of disagree I would say I don't want
them labeled domestic terror group I
think it gives the federal government
too much authority over American
citizens to infiltrate them and surveil
them and they've never killed anybody
the Bloods and the Crips I mean they've
done much more damage and killed many
more people white nationalist neo-nazis
killed many more people much more
dangerous they're not designated like
that it literally is a bunch of pale
white kids living in their parents yes
you can't throw a punch
they threw
they've not made any arrests well I mean
I would agree it's because of the people
in these municipalities don't charge
them and the police have a very
hands-off about okay can I just add
before it you gotta want isn't it
interesting that these guys don't pull
this crap in in New York or Boston or
Chicago it's only in Portland which
leads me think it's like 50 people yeah
it's it's not like this international
network of people that are getting
financing well you know I found myself
in agreement with so much it's been sick
because I think anybody disturbing the
peace anyone who's perpetrating violence
for whatever causes political or
otherwise they should be not only
stopped but they should be arrested I
don't know if the mass that's preventing
the arrests I don't know why no one's
been arrested to Andy's point but I will
say that in terms of the threat that's
where I see it somewhat differently I
think anti far means anti fascist I
think people who are protesting against
the kind of white nationalist fascist
actions that they perceive on the other
side can be legitimate protesters I
don't think they have to be viewed as
somehow a threat to the peace or to
society but you're not legitimizing anti
PFAs no that's right but I'm saying for
example Chris ray the FBI director said
just last week that more than half of
all the domestic terrorism in this
country is white nationalist domestic
terror if you want if the president is
sincere here let's not doubt him I think
if there's somebody that you want to
designate as a threat to us gosh who was
perpetrating most of the domestic terror
in America white made anti feet and he
fought beat and II know a gay I be agent
man I don't think he's alright look what
happened yesterday in California gunman
who was apparently posting like white
nationalist manifestos is killing since
2000 radical Islam and jihadists have
killed many more American citizens sure
than white nationalists yeah they only
count after 2001 and they are designated
as terrorists right yeah that's what
yeah that's and that's important see
that even after that rough start I got
everyone to agree I'm on a roll